whether you're on the verge of buying
your own home or one of the 91% of
millennial renters who want to buy a
home someday
the process can seem daunting it would
be lovely to skip right to that stock
photo moment with a realtor hands you a
key next to a sold sign but
unfortunately a lot of other stuff has
to happen first and the more you know
about it the smoother it will go so here
is an illustrated guide to the path to
home ownership from start to finish
[Music]
many people jump right into finding a
realtor or visiting open houses but the
most practical first step is making sure
you can get a loan unless you're paying
in cash in which case you get to skip
ahead a few squares but for most of us
the first order of business is choosing
a loan officer this is the person who
will secure a mortgage loan on your
behalf fun fact I used to be a loan
officer myself and I highly recommend
sourcing this person on personal
referral the loan officer will have you
fill out a pre-approval application that
will include your income credit history
and current assets you'll also have to
provide documentation like pay stubs
bank statements and tax returns be
prepared to share more financial
information with this person than you do
with practically anyone else in return
he or she will help match you to a loan
that's right for you there are many
different types of loans but generally
speaking the better your credit history
and the more money you can put towards
the down payment the better your terms
will be having a score of 740 and being
able to put down 20% of the purchase
price is the ideal but as long as you
have a credit score of around 680 and a
down payment of at least three and a
half percent your loan officer will be
able to provide you with some decent
options the loan officer will also help
you decide how expensive a house you can
qualify for and give you an idea what
kind of closing costs to expect closing
costs are all the extra expenses that
you'll have to pay to finalize the deal
and you should anticipate them to total
around 2% of the purchase price remember
your loan officer is not your financial
planner it's up to you to know how much
you're willing to shell out in total and
how large a monthly payment is
comfortable for you and keep in mind
that you don't have to have all your
ducks in a row in order to reach out to
a loan officer even if you're not quite
ready to buy they'll be
me to talk with you and tell you what
you need to prepare if everything checks
out in a day or two you will be
pre-approved for a home loan and now
it's time to add a new member to your
team their realtor your realtor is your
personal shopper and chief negotiator
it's their job to find you the home of
your dreams and help you make a
competitive offer realtors are not hard
to come by so it's especially important
that you pick one with good reviews or
has been personally recommended like
your loan officer your realtor typically
works on Commission which means they
don't get paid until the deal is done so
they'll be eager to get you into a home
as fast as they can now comes the part
most people look forward to finding a
house after looking at countless
pictures online and touring interiors at
some point hopefully you'll zero in on
the house that fits all the criteria
you're looking for so what comes next
you and your realtor will submit a
formal offer to the owner accompanied by
a letter of pre-approval from the loan
officer to prove that you can afford it
if they accept the clock starts ticking
on the purchase process from here on out
it's important that you don't change
anything about your financial situation
your loan approval is based on things
Sting's just the way they are so no
changing jobs or taking out new credit
cards the first part of the purchase
process is the option period you will
typically give the owner a deposit of
around 1% of the purchase price upfront
to show that you're serious in exchange
the owner gives you a window of around 5
to 10 days to inspect the house and
decide whether you want to go through
with it you'll definitely want to hire a
professional inspector to make sure the
house is safe and up to code and there
are no issues with big ticket items like
roof or a/c if you do find a major
problem you and your Realtor can ask the
owner to fix them or adjust your offer
accordingly after option is over you get
to relax a little bit while the loan
officer works on turning your file over
to the underwriter they are the ones who
hold the ultimate power to approve or
deny your loan and it's their job to
make sure you check out as a super
trustworthy squeaky-clean potential
borrower the loan officer will act as
your go-between and just like you will
want to keep this train moving so be
sure to promptly supply them with any
supplemental documentation they may need
once the underwriter gives you the
all-clear you will be clear to close
it's almost closing day time to get your
checkbook out by this point your loan
officer should be able to give you a
definitive number of how much you owe
and down payment and closing costs this
money is actually owed to a lot of
different parties but to make it simple
you'll pay it all to a title company
whose job it is to make sure it gets to
the right people you'll also have to
show up in person to sign a big stack of
papers which are then sent back to the
mortgage company and once they verify it
congratulations you own a home even
though the process is legally wrapped up
there's a couple more things to keep in
mind your first mortgage payment is
typically do this second month after
closing so if you close on June 15th
expect to write that first mortgage
check in August and don't forget about
moving costs even if you don't hire
professional moving services there's
utility set up costs restocking the
pantry replacing items that get broken
in the move or buying pizza and beer for
your dear friends that help you out no
doubt about it
buying a house is a big endeavor and
like most big endeavors the most
important steps come early on making
sure you have enough money saved and
recruiting the right team members and
that's our two cents
you
[Music]